Our daughter entered her life at 24 due
to depression.
If someone is determined to end their
life,
how can one change their mind?
Oh,
well,
first of all,
I'm very sorry about that.
That's a terrible thing.
Look,
I had this friend her.
Sorry.
There's been a lot of depression in our
family,
so it's a question that comes close to
the bone.
Anyways,
I had this friend and friend of my
parents and her grand daughter committed
suicide.
You know,
she was just beating yourself up about
that.
What could have I done?
What could've I done differently?
This is the problem with suicide.
It leaves everybody behind thinking,
Oh my God,
what could have I done?
I could have treated the person better.
I could have listened.
I could have been there.
It's like,
and she was just beating yourself up
about this really feeling that she
wasn't a useful person,
that she'd failed as a grandmother.
She was a really good person,
you know,
and so I went for a walk with her and I
said,
she's married and she likes her husband
and he's a really good guy.
And I said,
look,
you're,
you're blaming yourself for the,
for your granddaughter,
suicide.
It's like,
are you blaming your husband?
Are you sitting him down and telling
them what to use?
Useless bastard he was as a grandfather
because his grand daughter committed
suicide and how he failed completely.
She said,
no,
I'd never do that.
So I said,
well,
don't do it to yourself.
No people.
Depression was a terrible thing and
many,
many things cause it and we don't
understand.
We understand some of them,
but lots of them we don't understand at
all.
You know,
sometimes people get depressed because
they're really sick.
We know that depression can be an
inflammatory disease,
it might be associated with autoimmune
dysfunction.
There's lots of reasons that people get
depressed and depressed.
People can go places that are so dark,
you just cannot imagine it.
And it isn't necessarily the case that
you can always rescue someone,
you know,
and,
but,
but drowning yourself in the aftermath
of a suicide is not helpful.
So there's a,
there's a good room for self forgiveness
there.
You know,
I mean maybe you did some things you
shouldn't have done that were
reprehensible and all of that,
but you don't want to beat yourself up.
Remember the presumption of innocence,
right?
Innocent until proven guilty and you
have to apply that to yourself.
I don't think.
I think there are times when people are
so depressed there.
There isn't anything that anyone can do.
You know,
when the depressed person thinks,
and this is probably the worst part of
it,
the depressed person thinks
everywhere I look,
it's nothing but catastrophe and
there's.
I can't see any way out of it.
I can't see any path forward whatsoever.
And then they think as well and maybe
it's the combination of these two
thoughts that,
that really make people suicidal so like
it's hopeless.
It isn't going to get any better no
matter where I turned.
There's no escape.
The suffering is unbearable and I've
absolutely no use whatsoever.
Do anyone.
It would be better for everyone if I was
just gone because I'm going,
if I'm not so much of a burden now that
it's going to destroy their life,
then I'm going to be that much of a
burden in the future,
and so todd,
you imagine what that's like for people,
but it's dreadful and there's lots of
ways you get there and so you can listen
to people.
You can desperately encourage them to
seek the help they need.
You know,
like I've,
I've seen antidepressants work miracles
on very,
very many people now.
They don't work for everyone and they're
not a panacea but they have side effects
and all of that,
but one of the side effects of untreated
depression is that you kill yourself and
there is no recovery from that and are
the probabilities actually rather high.
So you can go to war with them about
antidepressants.
If the person can't get out of their
depression and their and their suicidal.
It's like,
what do they have to lose one month on
antidepressants?
They'll know,
oh,
they might have to experiment longer
because it would depend on,
you know,
some people respond better to some
classes of antidepressants than the
others.
Um,
it's worth having a war with someone if
they're in dire straits and they won't
do everything they can to get better.
ECT works.
Electric convulsive therapy works for
intractable depression.
It's a terrible thing to contemplate.
But the modern versions of ect aren't.
One flew over the cuckoo's nest.
And again,
it's like there's no coming back from
death.
So look,
it isn't clean.
You can't rescue everyone.
People get sick and they die,
and sometimes the way they die looks
like it's depression.
Depression is a multifaceted phenomena.
You can be there for them.
You can listen,
you can watch,
you can intervene,
you can try to understand,
you can hold them accountable.
You can do all of those things but that,
but everyone has their own destiny,
you know,
and you're not omnipotent.
And so sometimes a catastrophe will
curse like your daughters and
then,
and then you should try to drag the
least amount of misery forward that you
can once you recover from your grief.
Yep.